i hear you do some pretty good animal
impersonations
brace yourself everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
or how many earth places are there in
the solar system
earth places the round uh planets oh god
girl honestly i think we should just
trust our president in every decision
that he makes and we should just support
that you know and um
be faithful hydrogen is at the top of
the
solar system periodic table
what is a hydrogen hydrogen peroxide
is that what they use to put down their
eyebrows
hey everyone i'm jill biden's husband
i am the number one most impactful
artist of our generation i am
shakespeare in the flesh walt disney
nike google at night i be flying
i believe i can fly
i am a unicorn
you are a unicorn we are unicorns
do you know how powerful you are
what's the girl the famous girl
that there's a famous girl on a picture
there's a few famous girls on a picture
i keep wanting to say maria antoinette
she was a famous woman yeah remember the
girl that was sitting there like this
she was like
mona lisa yes
that's my girl
but i just want to thank everybody the
first responders
on behalf of myself our vice president
melania really wanted to be with us
she's really it's really touched her
heart what's going on and we've seen the
devastation melania really wanted to be
with us she's really it's really touched
her heart what's going on and we've seen
the devastation your favorite dish
my favorite dish
i like mugs because they're
very comfortable in your hand and they
hold hot things that you don't have to
touch
so um you know coffee
or hot tea so
what does carpe diem mean i think it
means like zen
it means seize the day
how come i don't know that we went to
school a long time ago what are the
three states of matter
what does nacl stand for
geometry here's a hint it could be found
at the dinner table turkey
[Music]
steak
water i am a god everybody says who does
he think he is i just told you who i
thought i was a god
i just told you that's who i think i am
you know
it is just wonderful to be back in
oregon and over the last 15 months we've
traveled
to every corner of the united states
i've now been in
57 states i think one left to go
one left to go alaska and hawaii i was
not allowed to go to even though i
really wanted to visit but my staff
would not uh justify it do you believe
the earth is round or flat the earth is
flat oh here we go earth is flat earth
i think you need to do research on it
like ultimately who's not gonna say the
research that you do is gonna give you
the and like who actually has the answer
because it's right in front of our faces
i'm telling you it's right in front of
our faces
they they lie to us who
look
for for what i've known
for as many years
and and which i've come to believe what
i've been taught
is that the earth is round yes but i
mean can you really think of us rotating
around
the sun and all planets aligned rotating
in
specific dates being perpendicular with
what's going on with these planets
they're particularly putting you in a
direction of what to believe and what
not to believe there's no there's no
concrete information except for the
information that they're giving us and
the truth is right there you just got to
go searching for it budapest is the
capital of what european country
budapest is the capital of what european
country nathan has already locked in i
thought europe was a country
budapest
i didn't even heard of that
like i want to say
is france a country
i don't know what i'm doing poppy copy
if you had to guess
do you have a guess
i don't think france is a country but i
would have said that i don't know i
don't know i'm just going to say france
i don't know france is a country i will
tell you that
the right answer
is hungry
is what
hungry
hungry
like i'm hungry
that's a country
i've heard of turkey but
hungary
never heard of it
what planet can sometimes be seen with
the naked eye
mars
i'm gonna say mars because it's like a
red it's a red dot eclipse eclipse you
can see the planet eclipse let's final
answer here's a hint it is the brightest
planet
oh son
wait what the star
girl
are you telling me that if you don't
have sex you can still get pregnant yes
because sperm lives inside the vagina
for three days who taught you this
uh she went to school and you should be
happy your daughter has an education
especially sex ed you obviously didn't
that's why you have multiple baby
daddies and thousands of children
[Music]
i wasn't ever good at math i was always
promised no math there will be no math
on this show
maybe by the end you'll be good at it i
know and then is math related to science
math is the language of the universe
numbers if you
want to go to china and speak to chinese
people you learn mandarin or yeah okay
go to spain you learn spanish yeah you
want to go to the universe you learn
math
it's
that simple i mean it's that
straightforward i know that people have
done this before on your show but i just
want to go and do it once
melania trump impression
okay i gotta get the face right okay
i love my husband
president
barack obama
and our children
sacha and malia
and by the way you know i sit on the
stand
and it gets hot i got a lot of i got
hairy legs that turn that that that that
that turn uh um blonde in the sun
and the kids used to come up and reach
into the pool and rub my leg down so it
was straight and then watch the hair
come back up again
they'd look at it so i learned about
roaches i learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
each planet has a sun and moon are you
ready they have multiples
no they don't each have a sun animal
they all have the same sun
they have multiple moons
i think earth is the only one that has
one moon
does that even sound correct sis
it didn't have to sound correct i said
it so it is so i remember i remember in
the clouds the teacher puts this like
board and there's like one sun one moon
and we all share it
okay courtney what the [ __ ] is up with
your wi-fi you have this big-ass house
and you can't afford a wi-fi box out
here it's not about affording it's about
radiation i don't even know what this
means but i'm gonna should i say the
word yeah say the word tuba
oh a tuba you know what a tuba is what's
the taba are you
let's get that just go just go
get out of
here oh
oh a horn thing
she's upset
i feel that if i had more resources i
could help more people
i have ideas
that can make the human race
existence within our hundred years
better
period i love that color that's such a
happy beautiful rich it almost kind of
looks like what the earth looks like
when you're a bazillion miles away from
the planet yes yes i just squinted at it
from the planet moon from the planet the
moon is star the no the moon is the
planet
the sun is a star is the moon really a
planet the moon is a planet don't look
at me like that the sun is a star
is the sun not a star i don't know what
the sun is we don't know what the sun is
the sun is a star
the moon is not a planet i
what else is it if a place it's not i
believe it's a star or something it's
not a moon it's something didn't you do
that thing in green school where you had
to name the planets and there was uranus
and there was saturn and the one with
the rings and the that and then the
earth
the moon is never in there dude it's not
a planet
all right here look this is key lime
i don't know i don't know what it is
besides what is it
i exposed during the shoes come on it's
a plan this blonde of mine
could be real okay um
a natural satellite the things live on
it that means it's a planet
is that what google said i don't know no
i don't like that at all i don't know
what that means